there was a conference at a silla mar
that made headlines around the world the
brightest minds of artificial
intelligence converged on a silla bar
and a reporter asked them a question
when will this fable singularity take
place when will the machines take over
when will machines become smarter than
us well the answer was quite interesting
among the top people assembled in one
place the answers were anything from 20
years in the future to a thousand years
in the future with some AI experts
saying never some people put it at 2029
they even give you an exact date 2029
that's going to be the moment of truth
that one day a robot will wake up wake
up in the laboratory look around and say
I am aware I'm just as smart as you in
fact I could be even smarter if I put a
few more chips in my brain other people
say not so fast not so fast because
Moore's law is going to break down the
reason why many people are so confident
about this prediction of the so-called
singularity is because of Moore's law
that computer power doubles every 18
months and it's C it's a curve that is
held sway for 50 years if you go back a
hundred years back to the time of
mechanical hand crank computers put that
into Moore's Law and you still get a
nice fit so believe it or not Moore's
law has been in operation for about a
hundred years going back to hand crank
calculators with computer power doubling
every 18 months well can this go on
forever and the answer is no because
eventually physics takes over and that
is physics says that silicon is unstable
at the molecular level transistors get
so small so powerful and they generate
so much heat that the silicon chip melts
and electrons leak out because of the
Heisenberg uncertainty principle you
don't know where the electron is anymore
therefore we physicists are looking for
replacements
silicon the post silicon era will be
about 10 to 15 years in the future
Silicon Valley could become a Rust Belt
think about it every Christmas your PC's
your computers your gadgets will be just
as powerful as they were the previous
year and then the question is are you
gonna buy are you going to buy any more
computer products for Christmas time
knowing that they're just as powerful as
they were the previous year
probably not which means that the
computer industry could begin to begin
to shake as a consequence so we
physicists are looking at optical
computers quantum computers DNA
computers protein computers all sorts of
different kinds of architecture down to
the molecular down to the atomic down to
the microscopic realm but none of them
are ready for primetime yet so my answer
is I don't know all I'm saying is
there's vast uncertainties in projecting
Moore's law into the future however I
would say by end of the century I would
say by end of the century it is
definitely conceivable that if we work
out the technical problems we might be
able to create machines that are smart
as us right now our machines are as
smart as insects eventually they'll be
smart as mice after that they'll be
smart as dogs and cats probably by the
end of the century who knows they'll be
as smart as monkeys at that point they
could become potentially dangerous
because monkeys can formulate their own
plans they don't have to listen to you
they can formulate their own strategies
their own goals and I would say
therefore at that point let's put a chip
in their brain to shut them off if they
get murderous thoughts
Isaac Asimov advocated something like
that with his three laws I say hey put a
chip in their brain to shut them off if
they start to get murderous